what's going on guys welcome to another
amazon web services tutorial video in
this video what i'm going to be doing is
acquainting you
with the command line here and getting
used to working within a terminal
instead of your typical
desktop with folders that you can see
and all this nice stuff
so initially when you start looking into
maybe
running your own web server you look
into this stuff and how
how you know connecting via ssh works
and all that
and this whole kind of thing is just so
intimidating that
you probably just get scared away and
you just don't want to deal with
something like that that's just that's
just too annoying right so some people
either just give up from there
or they just stick with something like
ftp
and a lot of web servers are actually
not even well they don't even come with
ftp installed you can install it and
then there is a couple options usually
that you're going to have to switch up
to allow for ftp transfers but
really you should just get used to
working within the terminal because you
can do a lot of stuff and it's going to
empower you with whatever server that
you buy
to do a lot of cool stuff and at least
with amazon web services
i'm not really sure what you're going to
do if you don't actually you know use
the command line so
this is just going to be a quick crash
course in the various
uh commands that you're going to be
using pretty much all the time
so with that let's go ahead and get
started so
to figure out like where you are you can
type
pwd and what that's going to do is it's
going to output basically the full
path to where you are so i'm at slash
home slash
ec2 users like that's my username right
i'm ec2 user
uh so that's going to give you where you
are now you oh
there's also a command for where you can
go so you can do ls
that's going to list out all the
directories that you can go to in our
case we literally have nothing
here um that's because the server is
just is
just brand new they give us a clean
server plus this is my user file uh
so there's nothing here but there are
there are plenty of things
on this file are on the server all
ready so to get there and kind of see
what else is here
the other things that we can do is you
can change directory
so if we had a directory to move into we
could go cd
and you know a new directory or
something like that like say we had
another directory but we don't
so to move back though you do a dot dot
and then sometimes you'll also see it as
a dot dot slash and so on but for
just easing simplicity it's just dot dot
so now we've moved
backwards and now we're in remember we
were in slash home slash ec2 user
now we've moved back and now we're in
home so now if we do ls
we see that we have an ec2 user another
thing that you can do is you can list
basically all so you can do ls
dash la and that's going to list even
a hidden files and usually they're
hidden with a period in front of them
and then there's like files like these
like d r
w x r i honestly don't know uh what
those stand for i've seen them before i
remember doing a tutorial like this for
my pi
i don't know what those files are if you
happen to know feel free to leave a
comment below
but we're not going to mess with those
but anyway you can do that to see also
like hidden files and stuff like that
uh subsequently we can you know go back
again
and then uh another thing you can do
just for quick access is you can hit the
up arrow and it gives you like the last
thing you typed and you can continue
hitting the up arrow for all the things
that you've done
uh so anyway we'll just continue going
back so we can see that we can't go back
any further so where are we
uh we've got all of these files here um
or folders rather they're actually
proper name is
directories anyway um so that's that so
that's how you can kind of navigate
and so you could be like okay well i
want to go back to home so cd home
now we're in the home directory ls cdc2
dash
user and now we're back uh where we
started
so that's how you just kind of bebop
around now let's say you actually want
to
start doing stuff on your server now if
you're just you know it's just you
you could put stuff wherever the heck
you wanted to but if you ever you know
if you're going to have multiple people
working on this server
sometimes it makes sense to keep
everybody's files underneath their
username
so we're going to just assume that's the
case and we want to keep keep that
working
so what do we do so if you want to make
a file
making files pretty easy there's uh two
commands basically to make files the
first one is touch
and that just literally makes the file
uh but i honestly i never use touch
because
you if you're gonna either you want to
open the file or you want to make
um you know like a new file but the only
time you're gonna make a new file you're
probably going to edit it right so
anyway
the other thing you can do so you can do
touch and then you can call it you know
new file.txt right but i'm not going to
do that we're going to do
nano new file dot text
and not only does it create it if it
doesn't exist it automatically opens it
up in your whatever
uh editor you're using here right so uh
so with nano being our editor
now we can do um pretty much anything we
want you know
example text yeah and then to exit you
can see all of the commands down here
uh so control x like that up arrow just
means control
x then it says do you want to save your
changes yes
and then as long as you always want to
you know save them to the same file just
hit enter
otherwise you can change the name and
you've created that file now if we ls
now we see new file.txt exists and again
if we nano into new
file.txt it's still there and it saved
it for us
now that we've done nano and what we can
do there
the other thing that we might want to
consider
is maybe we've started putting a lot of
files into ec2 user
and now we're like we should make
another folder or
directory and
maybe store some files there so we can
start organizing all these files that
we've made
so to make a directory it's pretty
simple it's just mk
der and it's obviously going to make it
either wherever you say or you can
specify a path but if you don't
you know specify it's just going to make
it right there same thing with files of
course
so um trying to think of what we could
call this
uh i don't know we'll make this this m
this uh directory called
epic you hit enter now we have that with
we ls we can see that we have this epic
directory
and a new file dot tax so now we can cd
into
epic and here we are now cd back out
again
and let's say now um we made this
uh directory and now we start we're like
well we want to move these files right
we want to move them
into that directory so how do we do that
well it's pretty simple uh all you're
gonna really need to do
is uh you type out
mv and then whatever the file is so in
our case we wanna move this new
file.text
and then where do you wanna move it in
our case we'll move into epic
so now when we go ls you see we no
longer have new file.txt but if we cd
into epic
and then ls we see that we do indeed
have
new file.txt in there so we've moved it
into that file or that folder rather
now what if let's go back uh
to our user ls here and we have epic
now let's make dir uh recycle
or actually let's call it trash uh
ls now we have epic and trash what if we
want to move every epic and its contents
to trash
well we would do envy epic
trash right so now we ls
it's not there uh cd trash
and here we are uh we see epic is in
there
um so not cd back out
oops and that's how
you move folders around
um finally let's do
nano dell me dot text
and we'll just exit we just wrote some
random stuff in there
yeah we want to exit so there's our file
how do we actually get rid of a file
that we want to get rid of well
to remove them you just do rm and then
dell me dot
text for example ls again and dell me
dot text
is all gone what if uh we've got make
dir
uh dell me so we've made a directory
called dell me
and if we want to get rid of uh what if
we want to get rid of that well
to get rid of a directory it's rmdir and
then what directory
in our case dell me and now you can see
uh it's gone
so that's going to cover the basics to
navigating the terminal
and doing a lot of you know basic simple
tasks
in the next video i'm going to be
introducing you guys uh
to python putting up a script in uh
you know making a script and running
that script within the terminal
and then i'm also going to show you guys
a few key files and point out just
a couple things that i had mentioned
earlier
so anyways uh stay tuned for those
videos as always thanks for watching
thanks for your support
and your subscriptions and until next
time